[Musique]
l'actualité sportive chargée michael on
commence par quelques jours elle
direction plaisir la série noire
continue pour plaisir les jaune et noir
ont concédé une quatrième défaite de
suite en nationale 3 les plaisirs oies
se sont inclinés contre haguenau sur le
score de 35 à 31 ce dimanche à domicile
les plaisirs aux a mené pourtant le 3
buts à la fin de la première période on
écoute la réaction de l'entraîneur
victor garrigues et à la fin du match
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup d'amertume parce que on mène à
plusieurs reprises de quatre buts et on
remet systématiquement l'adversaire en
selle en ayant bien trop d'échecs passes
ratées tirs manqués sur des solutions où
l'adversaire n'a pas forcément provoquer
notre note défaillance
après bon l'adversaire s'est battu
jusqu'au bout non qui mérite sa victoire
ça pas là le débat mais on donne
beaucoup trop de cartouches à notre
adversaire
et quelles sont les conséquences de
cette défaite au classement alors cela
devient compliqué un pur plaisir on va
le voir au classement cette défaite face
à un adversaire direct dans la course au
maintien aura peut-être de lourdes
conséquences pour la suite du
championnat
les plaisirs oies sont actuellement
lanterne rouge de la poule avec
seulement deux victoires depuis le début
de la saison mais le capitaine benjamin
modeste ne perd pas espoir
l'avenir c'est cette boulot déjà c'est
repartir à l'entraînement
costaud vaillant et puis qu'on retrouve
nos valeurs parce que là je trouve qu'on
perd vraiment notre emballé à cette
mentalité qu'on avait les dernières qui
nous a permis d'atteindre les barrages
pour la nationale 2 prochain match pour
plaisir le dimanche 27 janvier toujours
à domicile face à un autre concurrent
direct pour le maintien thionville
moselle handball l'avant dernier du
championnat victoire impérative pour
continuer à croire au maintien en fin de
saison
juste avant de vous laisser un mot de
handball féminin exactement of montigny
le bretonneux continue sa marche en
avant les musulmans tels ont remporté
une deuxième victoire consécutive sur le
terrain du paris saint germain ce
week-end les joueuses de denys choulet
se sont imposés 26 à 23 grâce notamment
à 8 réalisations de justin ribouleau au
classement les saint-quentinoises
remontée se retrouve maintenant à 7e
place du classement avec 20 points à
quatre petits points du podium
merci michael ce résultat et bien
d'autres encore à entrer dans le 7-8
sport notamment une grosse victoire des
templiers d'elancourt ans en football
américain